[MUSIC PLAYING]
GOPI KALLAYIL: All
right, good afternoon,
Yoglers and Googlers.
I'm delighted to welcome
to the Google campus
one of the most celebrated
names in Bollywood today, Shilpa
Shetty Kundra.
[APPLAUSE]
Shilpa's an actress,
producer, former model.
She's the winner of
the British reality TV
show, "Celebrity Big Brother
5" and has been nominated
for four Filmfare awards.
And over the years,
she's delighted us
with her acting and dancing
in mostly Hindi movies,
but also Tamil,
Telugu, and Kannada.
But more importantly,
she has this passion
for the art of wellness and
how we can transform ourselves
inside out through modalities
like yoga, meditation,
or good nutrition, which
is one of the main topics
she wants to share with us.
And if you get lucky, she
might actually lead us
through a short yoga practice.
So please help me
with a Bollywood-style
welcome to Shilpa Shetty Kundra.
Shilpa.
[APPLAUSE]
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: Namaste.
Wow, what an
amazing introduction
from the yogi himself.
I'm elated.
Thank you so much.
GOPI KALLAYIL: Thank you.
Namaste and welcome, Shilpa.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: Wow.
I'm at Google.
[LAUGHS] Yay.
This is fab.
GOPI KALLAYIL: With the
yoga practice in Googlers
called Yoglers.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA:
I know, Yoglers.
How wonderful is that?
So all of you actually do yoga?
[LAUGHTER]
That's terrible.
That's terrible, guys.
Let's hope we can change that.
So if I do come in
next time, let's
see more people saying yes to
that, like, more confidently.
GOPI KALLAYIL: Absolutely.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: Yeah.
GOPI KALLAYIL: No, we have
a pretty active program
with several hundred
classes a week.
Just in the San
Francisco Bay Area alone,
we have 50 classes every week.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA:
That's wonderful.
GOPI KALLAYIL: And
they're pretty packed.
But on your channel,
one of your signatures
is swastra ho mastra ho.
Right?
We got to make everyone do that.
So can you demonstrate it once?
And then I'll get
the whole audience
to join it a couple of times.
What do you say?
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA:
So swastra ho mastra ho
means stay healthy, and just
throw caution to the wind,
and just be happy.
So that truly is
my mantra in life,
stay happy and stay [INAUDIBLE].
So I do it like this.
Swastra ho, mastra ho!
GOPI KALLAYIL: All right, let's
do it with her a couple times.
Do it again.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: Yeah.
GOPI KALLAYIL: Everybody.
SHILPA SHETTY
KUNDRA: Swastra ho!
Mastra ho!
GOPI KALLAYIL: One more
time, a little louder.
SHILPA SHETTY
KUNDRA: Swastra ho--
GOPI KALLAYIL: With the hands.
Mastra ho.
Thank you.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: Normally,
you can see my biceps.
But yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
GOPI KALLAYIL: So I understand
you are here for a women's
empowerment conference.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: Yes.
GOPI KALLAYIL: How did that go?
And what is your vision
for empowering women
around the world?
SHILPA SHETTY
KUNDRA: Oh, my god.
Yeah, that went really well.
I mean, we're close to Women's
Day on the 8th of March.
And I thought this was
a great opportunity.
And when I was offered
it, I said, great,
I'll tour around the US.
And more importantly, I
think, since I've just
started this wellness series
through digital media,
I just thought this would
be a great opportunity also
to come and visit you guys,
learn from you, and help--
or rather, get help from you
to help me help the world.
And you know, I've been
acting for the last 20 years.
But this truly is my calling.
I really believe that
I became an actor
and I became someone who's
famous so that I could
be of some use in this sphere.
And for me, health
is truly my passion.
I've suffered with
cervical spondylosis.
I've seen people who
are near and dear
to me suffer with cancer.
And I've been able to
change my life through yoga,
through meditation, through
good eating habits, which I
call a lifestyle modification.
I never use the word
"diet" because I
think it's just so
vulgarized, the word
"diet," that the
minute you say "diet,"
people are put off by it.
They think it's going
to be bland food.
It's not going to be tasty.
It's going to be
sodium-less, oil-less.
So I said, how do I debunk these
myths with food, with health?
And there is a lot of
information on Google.
Great.
[LAUGHS] I just
thought I'll make
it easier through
my channel to make
it a one-stop shop for people
who really can't afford a gym,
don't have the time to
work out, don't know what
to cook for their children.
And I just think that women
especially are already
in such an empowered
position, since we're
talking about empowerment,
I thought to just give them
the knowledge and empower them
with the knowledge of health,
which I think is
something that is
far more powerful than the
feminist sort of empowering.
You know?
I thought to my channel
I'd be able to channelize
a bit of my knowledge
through the experts
that I have on my channel,
to be able to empower people
with the importance of health,
how important it is to breathe,
which we're not doing.
In this time and age, we're so
busy running after our goals,
we're not breathing.
Forget doing pranayamas.
How many of you
actually sit down
and take a breath of fresh air?
Very few.
Yeah, you do.
GOPI KALLAYIL: Yes.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: I'm not
directing the question to you.
[LAUGHS] But none of us sit
down and just inhale and exhale.
We don't do that.
Our chest isn't opening.
GOPI KALLAYIL: OK,
teach them right now.
Let's change that.
How do you do it?
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: Just--
GOPI KALLAYIL: Lead them.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: [INHALES]
You just open up, you know.
Inhale all the positivity.
[EXHALES] Exhale
all the negativity.
Trust me, there's lots of it.
OK?
And when you're
inhaling and exhaling,
you're not doing you just
from your chest and your body,
you're doing it from your mind.
So it's your entire mind and
soul that is getting purified.
You know, oxygen is
reaching your lungs,
and it's purifying your
body and your mind.
It opens up your mind.
And the space that you guys
are in-- trust me-- it's
going to help you a lot.
Your need your mind.
You're all mind workers.
And I just think that small
little things like that,
breathing-- chewing food.
Chewing food, how many of us
chew our foods up 32 times?
Each morsel has to
be chewed 32 times.
[INAUDIBLE] ayurveda.
Because that's the reason
we're given 32 teeth.
None of us do it.
We just [GULPS].
We just gobble it.
We've started gobbling our food.
We've stopped-- we
don't even concentrate
on what we're eating.
How many of you look at
your food with gratitude
and say, oh, my god.
Wow.
This is going into my body.
None of us do it.
You do it?
That's why you look so
pink, in the pink of health.
GOPI KALLAYIL: He looks
well-nourished, yes.
[LAUGHTER]
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: So we
just have stopped living.
We're just living.
We're not enjoying our life.
And I just think
that before it gets
too late-- because
I've lost a few people
that I love very
dearly to bad health.
And I just felt that
it was important for me
to take this up as a cause.
I mean, I've worked
with HIV patients.
And I've done something
in that sphere of health.
And I'm like, gosh, what
if we could actually just
rewind and live better
lives rather than reach
a point of no return?
We all do vitamin
doing injections today.
We're all D3
deficient, most of us.
80% of us are D3
deficient because we don't
want to stand out in the sun.
So I'm like, small
little things.
I just think I want to bring
focus to the old way of living.
And I want to do that
through this channel.
And it really comes out of my
heart and less from my mind.
And I've said this before.
The world is going digital.
And I thought, let me do it this
way because it will reach out
to more people.
I'm really happy, on
the day we launched,
we touched nearly 1.5
views, million views.
And it was a huge compliment,
and also reassuring
that people are
interested in health.
I don't know if they just wanted
to see Shilpa Shetty in lycra.
[LAUGHTER]
But [LAUGHS] that couldn't
have been the only reason.
So we have a few
subscribers now.
We've touched nearly 67K.
GOPI KALLAYIL: So
health, wellness,
and how to are one of
the popular categories.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: Yes, I've
answered all the questions.
He doesn't need to
ask me any questions.
GOPI KALLAYIL: No, nut
one of the accomplishments
we're very proud of,
among everything else,
is that you chose to be
what we call a YouTuber.
You've chosen a platform that
has more than a billion people
coming and watching some video
or the other every month.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: Yeah.
GOPI KALLAYIL: So in fact, the
audience may not have seen it.
Can we roll a video
just to show everyone
a little taste of what Shilpa's
channel looks like on YouTube?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Hello, everyone.
I'm here to tell
you why I'm here
and what this
channel is all about.
Out of the various things
that I have done in life,
the reason to start
this channel is
to bring about an awareness for
what I value the most, life.
How many of us
really value life?
Why is the quality of
our health deteriorating?
Why do we have to stay
dependent on artificial aids
like medication, vitamin
injections, and succumb
to deficiencies, diseases,
deteriorating immunity
and genes?
The answers to all
these questions
lie in one important fact, our
constant neglect and apathy
towards our own health.
The target of this channel
is to address both--
weight as well as health issues.
Those who cannot afford
a gym, or nutritionist,
or don't have the time for
a regime will be introduced
to a panel of experts in
various fields of health,
along with my limited
knowledge and experience.
To make the change, please
subscribe to the Shilpa Shetty
channel where you will find
quick, healthy, and tasty food
recipes made by me, yoga
asanas, simple fitness routines,
and challenges along the way
with weight loss targets.
Remember, there is no
better time than now
to start living healthy.
Maintaining your weight
and keeping fit is an art.
And the art is, keep it simple.
We'll show you how.
One last thing,
swastra ho, mastra ho.
[LAUGHS]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA:
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
I didn't know they were
going to play that.
Gosh, I did the whole
spiel on my own.
If I knew they were
going to play that,
I wouldn't have
to speak so much.
GOPI KALLAYIL:
Repetition is good.
So I have two questions
for you, Shilpa.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: Yeah.
GOPI KALLAYIL: First is, how
has the experience with YouTube
been?
And secondly, you've got some
of the smartest YouTube folks
sitting right here.
Do you have any ask for them?
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: Yeah.
I want to ask them to help me.
[LAUGHTER]
GOPI KALLAYIL: What
help do you want?
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA:
Obviously, I'd
love to hear from you how
I could popularize this.
And I realize why I think I'm
one of the first celebrities
to be a YouTuber.
Because it takes so long.
It takes so much time.
You know, we're such a pampered
lot and also spoiled in the way
that we are paid
for every minute.
And this is something
that I'm doing free.
And I'm saying this
with a lot of humility.
So I realized when I embarked
on this venture or this journey
that I thought, you
know, I'll just shoot,
and I'll just start
putting up stuff.
But it wasn't that easy.
There was work going into
what we are supposed to shoot,
what we are supposed
to actually put out,
targeting all the
important questions.
As a layman, what is it that--
how do we start off?
How do we keep that
interest going?
What is the first
thing that will catch
people's eyes or imagination?
How do we get them
interested in health?
There was so much homework.
And then the hours of shooting,
eight hours of doing yoga--
GOPI KALLAYIL: Yeah.
In one day?
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: Eight
hours every shoot of doing--
you know, six hours.
I couldn't do beyond that
because I started cramping.
And you know, when you
do yoga, you can't eat.
GOPI KALLAYIL: True.
SHILPA SHETTY
KUNDRA: So I was on--
I was just sipping
on liquids and fruit.
So our shoots would begin at,
like, 9:00 in the morning.
And I'd have to keep light.
GOPI KALLAYIL: So you were
fully enlightened by evening.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: No.
And the beauty of
it is I discovered--
I discovered so much
through that journey.
Because I mean,
when you do yoga,
you don't do it beyond an hour.
But at the shoot,
because I, obviously,
wanted to do my
best, and I wanted
to do it every
asana to my optimum
best because I wanted
people to realize that this
is what you can achieve.
So I didn't know I had
that kind of strength.
And I didn't know that
I could actually stay
without food for six hours.
And that's the power of yoga.
It truly is mind over body.
GOPI KALLAYIL: Absolutely.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: And so
till the shoot would go on,
I'd be OK.
And as soon as the shoot
was over, I'd be like,
give me anything to eat!
So that is amazing.
And then also with the cooking--
so we didn't have
a food stylist.
It's YouTube.
We had really [INAUDIBLE].
So we're, like, cost-cutting.
I said, we can't afford it.
This is not a normal shoot.
So everything from cutting
the vegetables to putting it
on the plate, and
showing it to people,
I've done it all myself.
And we did nearly
eight dishes a day
because we wanted a bank
before we started rolling.
And the minute we had
60, 70 videos in hand,
that's when I launched it.
But the work has been going
on for the last nine months.
So it was a lot of hard work.
And that's what I realized.
And then after you finished
it, I also had to dub it.
So every asana is dubbed by me.
So it was a lot of hard work.
So I realized why no
celebrity wants to do this.
I was like, good gracious god.
GOPI KALLAYIL: So
that's great feedback.
And we'll take it away.
And we're happy to share
some best practices with you.
But one suggestion is actually
that behind-the-scene story
you just told, that
itself will make
for an interesting episode.
Because people
want to hear that.
Your fans want to hear that.
So go back and relive
the production days--
one more video.
[LAUGHTER]
SHILPA SHETTY
KUNDRA: That's crazy.
But what did you take out of it?
I want to know from you because
you are a yogi yourself,
and you're very passionate.
GOPI KALLAYIL: Yeah.
So my biggest takeaway
is, when I was a kid,
I ran away to an ashram
and I learned yoga.
And we were primarily taught
by bearded men in orange.
It was an esoteric practice.
And thanks to now,
supermodels, super-actresses
turned super-yoginis,
it's become
more accessible to
a larger population.
It's got de-mystified.
And you frame it in
more contemporary terms.
And you make it accessible to
a lot of people otherwise who
would not have looked at it.
So I want to thank
you for doing it.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: How sweet.
Thank you.
And I want to thank you that
you're in San Francisco,
and you're such diligent
follower of yoga.
And you're trying to
spread the word, which
is really wonderful.
So a huge round of
applause for you.
GOPI KALLAYIL: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: Wonderful.
GOPI KALLAYIL: So
speaking of yoga,
one question, and then we'll
go into a practice mode.
Bollywood is not exactly
the right environment
for a yoga mindfulness
kind of practice.
It's a frenzied place.
Things move quickly.
And there's a lot of tension
and stress, and a lot of travel.
So how do you reconcile
those two worlds
and bring it together?
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: That's
a really interesting question.
That's why I'm not
doing movies right now.
[LAUGHS] I haven't done
for the last seven years.
I think maybe nine.
But I'm still here.
I'm still at Google.
And I've made my choices.
I've been there, done that.
I've been part of the milieu
for the last 20 years.
I do TV.
I choose to do that
because I can't be part
of this erratic timings and--
I have a
4-and-1/2-year-old baby.
And for me, I'm very
clear that that is my--
he is my priority.
My family is my first priority.
And I want to give time to
myself, and unapologetically.
And when you're an actor,
it's very hard to do that.
So I mean, obviously,
my recognition
comes through movies.
That will always be
my claim to fame.
I'm very proud of it.
But if I do choose
to do a movie,
I'll have to work
around my schedules.
It'll have to be a film that
will start and end quickly.
Also, I think I don't do yoga
because of the frenzied life
that we lead.
It's a very hard life.
You're constantly living
in a glass fishbowl.
And you're getting trolled.
Instagram determines how famous
you are, how much you're liked.
It's really shallow.
Though I have to say in the
most unhypocritical sort of way,
that I love that.
I love it.
I really do.
But the time that I
share with myself,
that, for me, is just my time.
You know?
It just helps me
cope with everything.
So even if I'm trolled, and if
somebody writes a bad article,
that's part of my life.
The morning that I wake
up, and I do my pranayama,
and I'm in the sun, basking in
its glory, and my feet are--
my feet is firmly on
the grass, that is life.
You know?
Just being able to do
that, to breathe the air
and to just live this
blessed life, for me,
that is far more important than
all the craziness of our job.
So I think that's what
keeps me grounded.
So a lot of people
tell me, how do you
manage to be so positive?
And you're, like, smiling.
I get upset.
I'm only human.
Of course, I get upset.
Of course, I go through
my times of why would they
write something like that?
But then I'm out of it.
I don't carry forward.
And I think yoga has
helped me do that.
Yoga has made me believe that
what cannot be cured has to be
endured.
And once you understand that,
life is so much more easier.
Otherwise, being an actor
is a really hard job.
Let me tell you.
And to be part of it for
the last 23 years has been--
I don't know how--
I don't know how I've
lasted out so long.
[LAUGHS]
GOPI KALLAYIL: Well, yoga,
meditation, you've told us.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA:
Yeah, really, really.
And I'm jet-lagged.
I have traveled all
the way from India.
And I've done Orlando,
and I've come here.
I've done an event last night.
I've barely slept seven hours.
But I got up, and I just
went out in the open.
And I just did a couple
of breathing exercises,
and I'm good to go.
GOPI KALLAYIL: Fantastic.
So would you lead us through a
practice and make us do that?
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: Sure.
GOPI KALLAYIL: But
before doing that,
I got one more thing for you.
We can't have Shilpa Shetty
here and not do a little thumka.
Right?
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: Oh, god!
[LAUGHTER]
GOPI KALLAYIL: That's like--
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA:
That's terrible.
GOPI KALLAYIL: That's
like having Michael Jordan
here and no slam dunks.
So teach us how
to do the thumka.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: Oh, man.
GOPI KALLAYIL: All right.
Can we have some music?
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA:
You can't do this to me.
This is really embarrassing.
For all of the
respect that I'm on.
[LAUGHS]
GOPI KALLAYIL: And
it's only on YouTube.
So only a billion people
will be watching it.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: Oh, great.
Thanks.
Yeah, lovely.
Yeah.
Get on with it.
GOPI KALLAYIL:
Thank you, Shilpa.
All right, so
everybody stand up.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA:
We need music.
GOPI KALLAYIL: He actually
is playing some music for us.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: On this?
OK.
How do we do this?
Yeah, come, come,
come, my friend.
Join me.
Come.
Come on.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE] right?
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA:
Only a billion people
have watched you.
[LAUGHS] Yeah.
OK.
SPEAKER: OK.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: This
is one of my first songs.
This is [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
SPEAKER: You have
to think about it.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: Yeah.
[SINGING LYRICS]
Yeah, [INAUDIBLE] this song.
It's in music.
Now, what song is this?
And I also don't
know what this is.
SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
GOPI KALLAYIL: Wait, Shilpa,
we need a few more people
joining you.
Right?
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: Yeah,
yeah, yeah, come on, guys.
GOPI KALLAYIL: How
many people want
to dance with Shilpa Shetty.
Come [INAUDIBLE].
OK.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA:
Come on to your sides.
Get on to your sides.
And now come up.
Yeah.
Sit down.
Yeah, we can all
sit in Sukhasana.
OK, if you don't know what
that means, just one leg up.
Sukhasana, "sukh"
means "happiness."
So it's the asana of happiness.
When you are in this asana,
the entire concentration
is on your core.
That's where all our
strength lies, our core.
What is pranayama?
Most importantly, before we
start, for all those people
who don't know the
meaning of pranayama,
"prana" means "life."
And "yama" means "control."
So the god of death is called
Yama because he controls life.
So pranayama actually is the
control of your life force,
which happens through breath.
So when they say
align your breath,
you are controlling
your mind through that.
And when your mind
is in control,
there's nothing that you
cannot achieve in life.
So most importantly, why we
lead such fast-paced lives,
even if we don't get the
time to do all the asanas,
if we just get the time to
just do a few pranayamas.
It takes 10 minutes.
And if 10 minutes can actually
align your mind, body,
and soul, life would
be so worth living.
So we'll start off with
the simple technique
of just inhaling and
exhaling through your nose.
OK?
When you inhale, let
your chest open out.
OK?
In dhyana mudra.
They say this is
the mudra of wisdom.
Your heart and your
mind are aligned.
On your knees.
Taking a deep breath.
[INHALES]
Exhale.
[EXHALES DEEPLY] Deep breath in.
[INHALES DEEPLY]
Exhale.
[EXHALES DEEPLY]
Once more.
[INHALES DEEPLY]
[EXHALES DEEPLY]
Wonderful.
We start off with Anulom Vilum,
where we take in the breath
through the left nostril.
OK?
So this is your hand.
Just keep it simple.
OK?
There's a more complicated
way of doing it.
I'm going to keep it
simple for you guys.
Just the index finger out.
All right?
The thumb, OK?
Or you can even do this.
So you basically need
to control your thumb
on your right nostril,
breath in through your left.
I'll do it once for you.
OK?
[INHALES]
[EXHALES]
Exhale through the right.
Then you inhale again
through the right.
[INHALES] [EXHALES]
Exhale through the left.
Inhale through the left.
[INHALES]
[EXHALES]
Exhale through the right.
Get that?
So this is Anulom Vilum.
We'll start.
OK?
We do five of these.
All right?
[SPEAKING HINDI]
[INAUDIBLE] Come do this.
He's far more learned than me.
He's been doing yoga for
so much, so much time.
[SPEAKING HINDI]
is like if you can
be in an asana for more
than an hour and a half,
you are actually going
to attain siddhi.
You become a true
yogi if you can
be in a pose for three hours.
I haven't reached
that stage yet.
[LAUGHS] So I'm not
yet a qualified yogi.
GOPI KALLAYIL: You do an
eight-hour shoot again.
SHILPA SHETTY
KUNDRA: Yeah, yeah.
No, when I still could be in one
asana for, like, three hours.
So I'm going to let
you lead the class.
That's my respect for you.
GOPI KALLAYIL: No, they
want to learn from you.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: No,
no, no, they've learned the--
no, I want you to
take the class.
Come on.
GOPI KALLAYIL: Go ahead.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: Ready.
[INHALES] Breathe
in through the left.
[INHALES]
[EXHALES]
Breathe out through the right.
Inhale and exhale long breaths.
There's no hurry.
Breathe in from the same
nostril that you've exhaled.
[INHALES]
[EXHALES]
Breathe out through the left.
Breathe in through the left.
[INHALES]
[EXHALES]
Breathe out through that right.
Breathe in through the left.
Breathe in through
the right, sorry.
I'm not very good at this.
Breathe out through the left.
Breath in through the left.
[INHALES]
Breathe out through the right.
[EXHALES]
Breathe in through the right.
[INHALES]
Breathe out through the left.
[EXHALES]
The last one, breathe
in through the left.
[INHALES]
Breathe out through the right.
[EXHALES]
Breathe in through the right.
[INHALES]
Breathe out wholly,
completely through the left.
[EXHALES DEEPLY]
Come into the dhyana mudra.
Eyes closed.
Concentrating on the center of
your forehead, the ajna chakra.
For all you Googlers, this
is the most important chakra.
It helps you concentrate.
And the sahasrara chakra,
which is right above that
in the center of your head.
Open up your mind.
And just breathe.
Open your eyes slowly.
And now we do Kapalbhati.
Gopi-ji is going to explain
the method of Kapalbhati
to you because he's
done many classes.
Basically-- yeah.
GOPI KALLAYIL: It's
a breathing technique
where you pump your lungs
up by forcefully exhaling
and let the inhalation
come in naturally.
So one way to get the feel
is to place your right hand
on your abdomen.
And exhale forcefully,
and just relax.
So the exhalation is forced.
The inhalation, you just
let it naturally come.
Then you do a series
of them like this.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA:
Shall we do sets of 20?
GOPI KALLAYIL: OK.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA:
We'll do two sets of 20.
You have to imagine, what
if a small little insect
has gone into your nose?
How would you take it out?
[EXHALES SEVERAL TIMES]
Yeah, that's
one way of explaining it.
GOPI KALLAYIL: 20.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: Yeah.
For people who've
never known yoga.
GOPI KALLAYIL: Blow
out 20 insects.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA:
Yeah, blow out 20 insects.
And you have to feel the air
be pumped from the center.
OK?
And what this
technique does, it's
a brain cleansing technique.
It's a very, very
powerful technique
and a powerful pranayama.
So we start, hands on your--
one hand on your
navel, the center.
Yeah?
Take a deep breath in.
[INHALES]
[EXHALES IN SHORT BURSTS]
GOPI KALLAYIL: One, one, one,
one, one, one, one, one, one,
one, one, exhale, exhale,
exhale, exhale, exhale, exhale.
Inhale.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: So you
are doing it the opposite way.
It's not
[INHALES IN SHORT BURSTS]..
It's out.
[EXHALES IN SHORT BURSTS]
So that's the movement.
Yeah?
And you don't have to
move your entire body.
It's only the breath and
your stomach that moves.
So it's not-- no.
Your body is upright.
Align your chakras.
You have to align
your back, straight.
And we do it again.
Everybody come into--
get your breath together.
Take a breath in.
[INHALES]
[EXHALES IN SHORT BURSTS]
Good job.
Very nice.
Wonderful.
I know a lot of you
have just started out.
So you require a
little more pressure.
But this is a great technique
to cleanse your nasal passage.
I'm down with a bad cold,
thanks to San Francisco.
I was out last night.
But this a great way
to cleanse your brain,
to oxygenate your lungs.
You suddenly start feeling
a glow on your face
when you continue with this
practice for maybe a month,
if you do it every day.
These three pranayamas, if
you can do every day, or maybe
four times a week, you
will see the difference
that it will have in
your life, on your life.
So I always say that
fitness is like a marriage.
You can't cheat on it
and expect it to work.
So you have to give it
some amount of your time,
commitment, and love.
So do you want to continue?
Should we do into Shavasana?
GOPI KALLAYIL: Do you want to
do a little asana practice?
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: Yeah.
GOPI KALLAYIL: A couple
of Surya Namaskar?
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA:
Surya Namaskar?
Wouldn't it be too
difficult for them?
GOPI KALLAYIL:
It's more likely--
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: As I do.
GOPI KALLAYIL: Go ahead.
Hit it.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: Ah.
AUDIENCE: There are three
pranayama, the Kapalbhati--
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA:
Kapalbhati and Anulom Vilum,
and just breathe
in, breathe out.
AUDIENCE: Bhastrika.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA:
Bhakstrika, no, Bhastrika
is still a little
more complicated.
You know when you start
off, you start with ABCD.
You don't start with XYZ.
So just these
three, concentrating
on your breath for 15 minutes.
Can I get a tissue?
Anybody have a tissue?
GOPI KALLAYIL: [INAUDIBLE].
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: I
normally never start with
the Surya Namaskar with
people who have just
started to learn because I feel
you need to spot them and make
sure that they're going
in the right position
when they're in Downward Dog.
I don't want anybody injured.
So I'm going to
show it to you once.
GOPI KALLAYIL: Many of
them are practitioners,
so you should be fine.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: Lovely.
[INAUDIBLE]
First and foremost,
before you get
down to doing the
Surya Namaskar,
we have to do a stretch.
Yoga is about action, reaction.
So every stretch has
a counter-stretch.
So before starting, just
loosen every part of your body.
Just shake it all out.
Yeah.
Hands.
Yeah, just like-- just move.
Yeah, just every part.
It's like a dance.
[LAUGHS] Yeah.
Just-- just-- just
warm your body up.
Yeah.
Just kick your legs around.
We'll just do the neck
rotation because it's
very important to warm up.
I cannot be more
emphasis on warm-ups.
Never get into a regime
or an exercise routine
without a warm-up.
So you just look to
your right first.
Center, slowly, to the left.
Center, look straight up.
Try and go as behind as you can.
Stretch your neck.
And you come down the same way.
Try to touch your
chin to your chest.
Right in the center,
straight ahead.
Rotate your neck now.
Three times.
Looking towards your right.
Come to the center.
Three times on
the opposite side.
And we go into Tadasana, OK,
where you stand like a tree.
Hands up.
Try and touch the skies.
On your toes.
Open out your chest.
Breathe.
Down.
Hands on the side, come down.
We do the same thing again.
Go into Namaste right on top.
Stretch.
Down.
Try to touch your fingers
to the ground now.
Breathe out.
[EXHALES]
Breathe in.
Come up.
[INHALES]
[EXHALES]
Can we do that again?
And when you do it the
second time, trust me,
you will go down lower.
Hands up.
[INHALES]
Exhale.
[EXHALES]
Inhale.
Come up.
[INHALES]
Hands on the side.
Come down.
We do the Surya Namaskar?
GOPI KALLAYIL: Yeah.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: Ready?
[INAUDIBLE]
GOPI KALLAYIL: They have
two, three, minutes, and then
we're out of time.
SHILPA SHETTY
KUNDRA: Oh, lovely.
So only I'll be doing
the Surya Namaskar then.
GOPI KALLAYIL: We'll
do it together.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: Come,
let's do it together then.
Yeah?
GOPI KALLAYIL: Yes.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: Make sure
that the breathing technique
is right.
So with every asana, breathe in.
Breathe out.
One leg behind.
Chest, butt up, chest
to the floor first.
And knees on the floor.
Bhujangasana.
Now you get into a Downward Dog.
Make sure that the
heels touch the ground.
Try to go towards your navel.
One leg in front.
Then the next.
Come up slowly.
Hands up.
Into Namaste.
How did that make you feel?
Awesome, right?
Let's do that now in one go.
Yeah?
You got the technique.
Ready?
Hands up.
Bend backwards.
Down.
Butt up.
Only knees touch the floor.
Downward Dog.
Let's do three of these.
One more, OK?
Hands up.
Down.
That's fantastic.
Make sure when you go
down, that position,
I feel most people do it wrong.
When you go down,
when you are here,
make sure you go down like this.
This is the right way to do it.
Most people do this.
That's not the right way.
So only your-- this
is the way to do it.
Then you come up.
And then you go do this.
In Downward Dog, try and always
concentrate and go backwards.
I just showed it to you.
When you guys do it, you
need to get this right.
OK?
We'll just do one more asana.
We do the Virabhadrasana,
which is my favorite asana.
It's great for the legs.
OK?
Feet hip width apart.
Yeah?
Lovely.
Now, you turn one leg.
Hands on the side.
Hands on top.
Bend.
Breathe.
You should feel the tension in
your glutes, on your thighs.
Come up.
Turn to the other side.
Center.
Hands on the side.
Yay!
That felt great.
GOPI KALLAYIL: Beautiful.
Thank you.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
GOPI KALLAYIL: With
that, thank you, Shilpa,
for a wonderful class.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA: Thank you.
GOPI KALLAYIL:
And namaste again.
Thank you.
SHILPA SHETTY KUNDRA:
Thank you so much.